i don't think there's ever been a
monitor with more features than
samsung's m8 but even i were sitting and
talking about how we wish that our new
display could have basic computing tasks
without having a computer connected and
then one hour later i saw the launch of
the m8 and i bought one immediately then
a few days later samsung reached out and
they wanted to sponsor us and send us
one of these weeks before my personal
order arrived so let's talk about how
this performs what it offers and what
are its downsides i've bought a lot of
displays in the past but was looking for
something that i could use in my home
that was not only 4k but looked clean
and modern so that it wasn't an eyesore
for our windows pc and this not only fit
that but blew my mind with the crazy
amount of capabilities while having a
relatively low price tag especially for
its features starting off with the
design it looks like a really clean
all-in-one with super slim bezels on the
top and the sides and a thicker but
still thin chin at the bottom with a
little piece at the right side for your
wireless connectivity an ir blaster that
is used for the included minimalistic
remote that gives you controls and
shortcuts and it's also rechargeable via
usb type c of course you can also
control it using your smartphone with
the smartthings app which is also used
for easy setup the m8 is mostly made
from plastic that is surprisingly
fingerprint proof especially the back
which has a herringbone pattern that
makes it look more premium and
interesting the back is also the only
part of the monitor that has a small
clean looking logo the stand is
surprisingly heavy with a full metal
base at over five pounds and it is
height adjustable so my kids can lower
it for themselves and then i can raise
it for optimal height all of the ports
are hidden right behind the stand which
is a nice design choice because it makes
routing and hiding cables a breeze for
connectivity we have two usb type-c
ports one of which will provide up to 65
watts of charging for connected devices
as well as the displayport signal and
taking data from the webcam and the
microphone to your pc or your mac
there's also a micro hdmi port with an
included cable that connects full-size
hdmi devices now being a smart monitor
you can also connect a bunch of devices
wirelessly including apple devices with
airplay from a mac ipad or iphone what's
even cooler is that you can wirelessly
connect to your samsung phone or tablet
with dex and remotely use your mac or
windows pc and since the m8 can connect
to keyboards in mice either wired or
through bluetooth you can get a full
desktop experience without having to
have an actual computer connected or
just open the built-in web browser and
use the m8 by itself as a computer which
is enough for basic day-to-day tasks
that are done on the web or access
office 365. this is something that i
would love to see more monitors include
especially ones that have powerful
hardware already built in and are
capable of way more than what the
software allows this makes it a perfect
computer to have anywhere in the house
because it looks good and because it
doesn't become useless if you don't have
a computer connected to it of course
it's a full-on smart tv with netflix
youtube apple tv disney plus and many
more apps including a ton of free
channels with samsung tv plus so when
you're not using it as a computer
monitor you could stream anything you
want with it or to it from your
smartphone and the display is actually
surprisingly nice but we'll get into
that in just a bit on the back we have
magnets and pins for samsung's slim fit
camera which just pops right in place
and connects automatically
this allows the m8 to have super thin
bezels without having a big forehead
while having a really nice large sensor
and lens for their webcam now most
people just talk about the resolution of
their webcam but the quality can vary no
matter what it is but because of the
size this 1080p webcam looks better than
most on the market and it also has face
tracking and zooming capabilities built
in you can also tilt the webcam up or
down to get the right angle without
having to tilt your full monitor and
what is even cooler is the small
magnetic privacy cap that stays on the
back when you don't need it or when you
do it will just literally easily
magnetically attached to the front of
the lens you really can't think of a
better webcam solution than what the m8
has it has really the best of everything
and the webcam and mic shows up and
works without having to install any
software on your windows computer or
your mac or you just use the built-in
duo app for web calls without a computer
i have to commend samsung for making it
so easy to use and giving people so many
options without locking us in for
example you get to choose if you want to
use bixby as a voice assistant or amazon
alexa i've been using alexa for many
years controlling my smart devices so i
added it to the m8 and it pretty much
turns it into a huge echo show so when
i'm across the room i can ask it
anything and it will respond and even
show things on the display itself and
since it has adapted picture both the
screen brightness and the color
temperature will adapt to your room so
that it's not way too bright and cool at
night when you choose to watch a movie
which is something that is always an
issue with regular monitors especially
ones that make you dig deep into a menu
to get to the adjustments now if all of
that wasn't enough the m8 is also
probably the first display that has a
hub built in for smart devices to
connect to and to be controlled by so a
bunch of devices regardless of the brand
can be connected to it and controlled
using the smartthings app without having
to use dedicated separate hubs now sure
it is a large 32 inch size with a 4k
resolution which gives us a ppi of a
hundred and forty now if you're somebody
that's coming from say a 1080p 24 inch
display that is 92 ppi so look quite a
bit sharper even though it is much
larger 27 inch 1440p monitors are about
108 ppi so this is still sharper but i
personally am used to a 5k 27 inch
display which is up to 218 ppi now of
course those are way more expensive and
they don't come with any of the smart
features so as far as resolution you
can't really complain especially for the
price point as far as brightness it is
rated at 400 nits which is above average
but to our eyes and even our cameras
meters it seems to be reaching brighter
levels than that
the display is matte to combat glare so
i was a bit worried about contrast but
to our surprise it has better contrast
than apple's best ips panel paired to
glass instead of a regular matte film
now that is because samsung is using a
va panel that has lower viewing angles
but much better contrast which makes
blacks a lot deeper giving your
highlights more pop as well as far as
color accuracy it has a billion color
range and 99 srgb so it will work for a
lot of people and as always i would
suggest getting a calibrator for serious
photo or video work the speakers get
quite loud so you can use it for playing
music watching movies or anything else
across the room but being that this
thing is so incredibly thin it does lack
bass so if you're gonna be watching
movies which it is really good at i
would suggest adding some dedicated
speakers like most would be for their
computers or maybe some kind of a sound
bar other than that the only downside
would be the external power brick
because of the ultra thin design of this
monitor but even though i prefer
internal ones for a device like this
that's supposed to be sleek i think they
probably made the right choice overall
the m8 is an absolute killer value
offering so many features for the money
and it is perfect for a home office a
dorm room or really anywhere where one
device can not only be a monitor but
also your main tv and so much more let
me know your thoughts about it down
below and check out the link in the
video description to get more info click
above to subscribe and check out one of
those great videos right over there
thank you guys for watching this been
max and i will see you in the next video
[Music]
you